[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
den cremigen cheesecake gegen ihn je
probiert habt und ich habe ihn als
ramadan kuchen gebacken denn oben drauf
ist der symbolische halbmondes ramadan
und peter käsekuchen besteht zuerst aus
einem teig dafür benötigen wir 300 400
flammte butter die habe ich schon ein
stückchen geschnitten 100 gramm zucker
einen teelöffel backpulver und ein ei
und für den mürbeteig der ist ganz
einfach gebe ich jetzt erstmal den
zucker und backpulver in das mehl und
verrühren das kurz mit meinen händen
und dann gebe ich das auf die saubere
arbeitsfläche dann kann man einfach viel
wenn verkneten
da gebe ich ja noch die butter mit
hinein und versuche das schon mal mit
meinen händen so zu verlängern
[Musik]
zwischendurch kommt auch noch dass ein
mit hinzu und wird dann zu einem glatten
teig geknetet
der muss jetzt nicht kühlen also der ist
schon sehr weit aber wir können jetzt
direkt die springform damit auskleiden
ich habe hier eine 26 cm springform ich
weiß jetzt schon tage gebrauchsspuren
ich da müssen wir schon sehr lange und
sehr gerne den teig gebe ich jetzt
erstmal auf den boden der springform und
arbeite mich dann an den rändern hoch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die überschüssigen rand nehme ich jetzt
noch mit meinem marzipan besser ab ich
habe den rand peter fünf zentimeter hoch
gelassen und nimmt da jetzt auf jeden
fall kein scharfes messer damit ihr eure
springform nicht zerstört den
überschüssigen talg gebe ich dann noch
auf die freien stellen der vorbereitete
wirkt teil kommt jetzt in den
kühlschrank am besten sind ca 15 bis 20
minuten und ich zeige euch schon mal die
zutaten für unsere leckeres füllung wir
benötigen ein kilogramm frischkäse der
doppel rahmen stufe 260 gramm zucker 200
zentren fresh 200 gramm magerquark 50
gramm speisestärke die habe ich bereits
gesiegt das ist auch wichtig damit keine
klümpchen entstehen ein esslöffel
vanille extrakt und den saft einer
halben zitrone
die masse die geht auch zu vereinfachen
gebe es als erstes den zucker hinzu die
reihenfolge ist eigentlich vollkommen
egal macht uns wo wir am besten können
danach gebe ich noch zu frisch und
magath hinein und frühere das
miteinander und auch die zuvor gezeigte
speisestärke kommt hinzu und wird gut
miteinander verrührt
dann noch den leckeren saft der halben
zitrone hinzugeben ich bin das gibt noch
mal so eine erfrischende note und wer
eine bio zitrone zur hand hatte sollte
auch unbedingt noch die zitronenschale
die hineingeben und auch den vanille
extrakt erkennt man im export hat der
kann auch vanillezucker nehmen auch kein
problem alles noch mal gut miteinander
verrühren und dann ist die käse machte
auch schon fertig anschließend nehme ich
mit meinen durch gekühlten mürbeteig und
gäbe da die käsemasse drauf nachdem dann
der kuchen auch an der oberfläche schön
glatt verstrichen wurde kommt er bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze für höchstens
60 minuten und rufen schaut aber nach 50
minuten mal wie er aussieht
für die deko habe ich hier noch 200
gramm frisch aufgeschlagene war und
verstreichen sie mit meiner winkel
verletzte auch mein kuchen
mit den frischen heidelberg jetzt noch
ein schöner halbmond gelegt
[Musik]
so schnell und so einfach könnt ihr also
einen eigenen ramadan kuchen machen
perfekt zu gäste perfekt wenn ihr
eingeladen seit nimmt ihn einfach mal
mit überrascht euren liebsten damit und
er schmeckt so unglaublich krimis ich
glaube es gibt keinen besseren weg als
diese wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und freue mich wenn ich sie
abonniert damit ihr auch nichts mehr
verpassen
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]